c'est comme ça que ça circule pas assez
quand on que ça s'est passé quand on a
tenté de refouler les manifestants qui
est tentaient de prendre d'assaut les
colonnes du pouvoir au Brésil ça tombe à
l'instant là d'ailleurs il y a Moscou
qui a pu totalement et entièrement Lula
et qui dénonce les manifestations de
cette tranche de bolsonaris on va tout
de suite aller retrouver Serge boire
notre collaborateur pour en parler ce
matin Serge bonjour d'abord est-ce que
je peux voir dans les tous derniers
développements là c'est le gouverneur de
l'état où se trouve la capitale
brésilien qui lui a été suspendu par la
Cour suprême du Brésil
ouais ben on déjeune hier on se disait
que c'est clair qu'il y avait une
organisation locale dans toute cette
histoire là ce matin le juge de la
course suprême Alexandre Mores qui le
suspense ses fonctions parce que déjà là
hier Marc-André hier après-midi début
d'après-midi on voit toute cette poule
de bolsonariste majoritairement des ex
militaires des gens qui ont fait qui
était dans l'armée qui se dirigent vers
la place des trois pouvoirs à brésiliens
escorté par la police et qui on les
laisse arriver sur l'esplanade des trois
pouvoirs et on a et vous avez sûrement
vu toutes ces images là de nombreux
policiers de nombreuses personnes des
forces de l'ordre qu'il les regardent
attaquer les trois les trois édifices en
question qui prennent des photos qui se
prennent en photo devant ça alors on
voyait clairement que toutes les forces
de l'ordre la police militaire les
forces armées étaient où ou complices ou
du moins des complices silencieux et là
ben on s'est rendu compte assez
rapidement que le gouverneur de l'État
en fait le gouverneur district fédéral
c'est dans le menteur du district
fédéral de s'occuper de la sécurité de
brésilien absolument rien fait le son
secrétaire à la à la sécurité publique
était l'ex-ministre de du gouvernement
de la justice et là on voit que toute
cette manifestation là qui vit en
grabuge s'organise et le secrétaire de
la sécurité du district fédéral prend
l'avion et sans vos États-Unis
probablement rejoindre monsieur
bossunarro alors c'est pour ça qu'on
était en train de démêler ce matin mais
c'est assez clair assez évident que il y
avait des appuis politiques dans ça le
gouverneur hier soir du district fédéral
qui est venu nous dire à la télévision
qu'il est question inacceptable mais on
voyait bien dans son visage c'est
absolument pas plaisir ça donne
l'impression quand on a un gouverneur du
district fédéral qui s'en va aux
États-Unis comme ça ça sent la fuite un
peu comme comme bolsonaro c'est
l'impression pour nous le Caron
peut-être manquer la cérémonie
d'investiture de Lula il est parti avant
bolsonaro il y a jamais dit bonne chance
Lula il a gagné les élections en
légalement au contraire d'ailleurs ces
partitions continuent de dire que c'est
une fraude alors ça ça ressemble à ça et
ce qu'il est tout de suite qu'est-ce
qu'il dit
tout le monde était au Brésil on a eu
quatre ans de gouvernement bostonaro 4
ans à se faire dire que la meilleure
façon de régler le problème du Brésil
c'était le retour de la 17e
38 ans de carrière politique il a
commencé sa carrière politique comme ça
alors tout le monde ici on s'attendait
que lundi et dimanche dernier pas hier
mais il y a eu jour lors de l'investit
il se passe quelque chose lorsque
Monsieur boursonaro est parti deux jours
avant on a tous un peu hausser les
sourcils en se disant qu'est-ce qu'il va
préparer qu'est-ce qu'il trame qu'est-ce
qui se passe il a passé deux mois depuis
le 30 octobre il ne s'est fait
absolument pas manifester à part deux
petites apparitions publiques et c'était
enfermé dans le palais présidentiel pour
finalement prendre l'avion
présidentielle et aller se réfugier aux
États-Unis je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a
une partie de la réponse de ce qui était
en train de préparer je pense qu'il est
il est probablement eu et là on assume
des choses marquandrine mais
probablement qu'il est le grand chef
d'orchestre de ça mais qui voulait
absolument pas que ça sache il pouvait
probablement qu'il va dire aujourd'hui
parce qu'il a fait un Twitter 10 ans que
c'est condamnable ça a pas de bon sens
et qu'en étant pas au Brésil il pourrait
pas besoin de porter l'audio de tout ça
maintenant est-ce que les États-Unis on
va voir aujourd'hui va être une journée
très occupée est-ce que Joe Biden et les
Américains vont le garder en sol
américain c'est ce qu'on va voir bon
d'ailleurs ce serait pas le seul
latino-américain à se retrouver en
Floride ça semble être le repère de ceux
qui sont déchus qui a cette continuité
de gouverner même qu'ils s'en sont pas
élus est-ce qu'il y a une appétit dans
dans l'armée brésilienne pour repenser à
des coups d'état ou prendre des
contrôles militaires comme ça a déjà été
le cas dans l'histoire
non et c'est ce qui nous avait laissé un
peu tout ce moins inquiet je dirais
encadrer avec ce avec cette passation du
pouvoir c'est que on savait des gens que
monsieur bossonaro était pas en théorie
dans le palais présidentiel pendant deux
mois pour rien il essayait d'avoir des
appuis et on savait qu'il avait à peu
près que le haut commandement de l'armée
derrière lui mais que les forces
terrestres dans la reine et tout ça les
soldats les militaires n'étaient pas ne
l'appuyez pas là-dedans on a vu hier
qu'il appuyait c'est une petite portion
parce qu'on dit que ces gens-là se sont
majoritairement des militaires hier qui
qui ne sont plus dans les armées qui ne
sont plus dans l'armée qui voulaient ça
et je pense que s'il y avait eu à se
passer quelque chose hier ils avaient
l'occasion là on leur a laissé le champ
libre et ils se sont plus se livrer à du
saccage qui a une tentative de prise de
pouvoir bon alors brésilien c'est pas la
plus grande ville au Brésil c'est ça
peut-être qu'ils vont peut nous
surprendre dans les autres grandes
villes ça polo ou encore Rio pour est-il
y avoir des des
manifestations semblables parce que ça
pourrait inspirer des groupes comme ça
parce que il y a beaucoup de gens dans
ces villes là
où on parle d'un ville d'environ 20
millions d'habitants l'agglomération
urbaine et je dirais qu'il y a ça
m'inquiéter dans l'après-midi quand tout
ça a commencé de voir que c'est un
panneau il y avait un début de
manifestation ici sur l'avenue par liste
et c'était un peu ce qu'on surveillait
et on s'est rendu compte qu'il y a eu
des petites manifestations locales un
peu partout au Brésil mais Pacifique
rien de ce qui se compare à Brasilia je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on a on a vraiment
et avec tout ce qu'on a vu hier soir je
suis pas certain qu'il y a quelqu'un qui
va avoir l'intention de de réessayer
mais évidemment on va on va surveiller
la situation je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
messages hier soir le président Lula
était très clair la classe politique a
été très claire tous les partis
politiques être humain celui de Monsieur
bonsonaron condamné ces événements-là et
aujourd'hui je pense que la force de la
loi la force du pouvoir démocratique va
démontrer à quel point il faut condamner
mais condamner pleinement avec des
peines de prison
et merci beaucoup Serge à la prochaine
merci pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]